okay let's be honest here
how do you feel
i mean really feel
when a meeting on your calendar gets
cancelled
might you sport a big smile give
yourself an air high five
if you're like most of us reclaiming
some free time at work brings a sense of
joy and relief
yet we all know that most of the work we
do requires and benefits from
coordinating and collaborating with
others
how can we maximize the benefits of
working with others while avoiding the
friction and challenges that often come
along for the ride
welcome to think fast talk smart the
podcast
today i am super excited to be joined by
bob sutton who is both a professor of
management science and engineering at
the stanford school of engineering as
well as a professor by courtesy of
organizational behavior at the gsb
his research and practice focus on how
to improve the way we work
he is the author of many books including
scaling up excellence getting to more
without settling for less and the no
rule
welcome bob
it's great to be here you know we're
recording this at a safe social distance
so i know you can't see the smile on my
face but for a while now i have been so
eager to chat with you on the podcast
because i've really enjoyed our previous
conversations me too they've been fun
let's jump right in
in your work and collaborations you
refer to friction what do you mean by
this and how does communication or the
lack of it contribute to friction boy
well that's quite a question so the
friction stuff essentially my buddy
co-author huggy rao and i we just got
interested in the notion that so many of
the organizations that we know that we
work with
would essentially make the right things
too hard to do and the wrong things too
easy oh no so so so that's
and you know the classic thing uh in
many i'm sure your listeners can relate
i don't really understand why some
organizations i know very well uh make
it so hard for me to get uh 25
reimbursed that i don't even bother i
just pay for it myself just it's sort of
at the most basic level
and to things like uh
for us as customers when we have a
journey through an organization that's
much more difficult than it need to be
for communication uh to me a lot of what
a leader's job is is to be clear about
where people should focus attention
and where they should um not focus
attention and and just somebody who
comes to mind immediately one of the
most effective ceos at one point i knew
well
uh was a.g lafley who was twice uh ceo
of procter and gamble
and and one thing he realized was
there'd be a lot less confusion about
where people needed to focus their
attention if as he said i did two things
i kept thinking sesame street simple and
i said it over and over and over again
until it was done and so to me that
that's part of the friction um challenge
for a senior executive is to get people
to understand where they should focus
their attention um and what should not
focus attention and what they should do
now and what they should do later or not
at all so that's just one example of how
communication would get you to friction
i see so it's all about keeping it clear
keeping it concise and simple and just
repetition so collaborating connecting
and coordinating with others is
absolutely essential at work yet working
with others our peers our bosses our
subordinates can be so draining and
frustrating how can we maximize the
benefits of working with others while
avoiding some of the downsides two
things when i think of collaboration
problems two things come to mind that
that i think that people really need to
focus on one just is is the notion that
that in your team look at the notion
that there are often people who are just
on the sidelines and are never asked to
be involved um sort of who are
ostracized or not viewed as relevant and
then there are people who suffer from
collaboration overload there's all sorts
of evidence including from my uh
researcher named rob cross
on the east coast that essentially
you've got three to five percent of the
people will do 35 of the work on many
teams oh wow and and those beleaguered
people if you are one well please even
get people to help you and if you're if
if you're thinking of that person in
your group who you always ask every
question of maybe you should try to help
them more and and those people are
essential they get beleaguered they get
burned out they quit they get cynical so
that's the first one is is to sort of
look at the
at the uneven distribution of who does
what the second thing and if you look at
those of us who study organizational
systems and
and i know you do as well matt is i'd
look for any place where there's
handoffs because when there's handoffs
between people between silos those are
the places where the conflict where the
misunderstanding happens and and as a
leader what your job is is to have
everybody for example in every silo and
every shift
understand what it feels like to be the
giver in the receiver in the handoff
situation um so so i guess handoffs and
collaboration overload is where i'd
start but we're not going to resolve
this in this brief podcast unfortunately
right you know uh thinking about where
those transitions are is critical we
have on this podcast talked a lot about
transitions transitions within an
individual communication from point to
point transition between individuals in
the communication interaction and what
you've added to this now bob is this
notion of transition between
organizational and function you really
have to think about what is it i'm
passing off how do i do that in a way
that's clear and concise how do i make
sure that that information was received
it's really really critical and and i
appreciate that and and also having the
awareness of where
all of the action and work is being done
also helps so i think that's that's
that's great
clearly work has changed dramatically
due to covid19 what are you seeing is
some of the biggest challenges and how
can business leaders address them
one of the things that's really striking
me with as so many of us have switched
to work from home
is is that um we're starting to realize
that uh we're more complete people we
are bringing literally we are bringing a
more complete version of ourself to work
so that's both a challenge for the more
pressure that people have when they're
in a situation where it's hard for them
to work and it's also an opportunity for
us to design our organizations for
people have complete lives so that's one
thing that really does strike me in
terms of organizational design so that's
sort of a good thing
then there's sort of a bad thing and
it's interesting we were talking about
collaboration overload a little bit
before
one thing that that i'm seeing
and there's a number of uh organizations
i'm working with and i think i may even
be seeing this at stanford too
is is that um in general um what happens
is is that um a lot of the companies i
know are moving really fast a number of
the technology companies i'm working
with are
moving really fast and part of it is
because with the the online stuff uh
there's not the opportunity for the
informal gossip
for
people to get together after work to
bump into each other so you're ending up
with a small group of decision makers
moving really quickly who are not um
getting as much input from from people
who are kind of on the sidelines and not
officially pulled into the conversation
that sounds like a recipe for disaster
yes it's it's kind of a recipe for to
move really fast and to and to kind of
have if you will organizational debt do
you think everybody's on board because
the same seven people you talked to in
the zoom call every day all agree but
there isn't even um hardly any
communication with anybody else at all
and i'm seeing this in fortune 10
companies uh and and it's really cool
how fast they're moving now and and the
smart ceos are worried that the chickens
are going to come home to roost
uh i want to turn our attention to
meetings and you and i have had some
interactions about meetings before you
know one way we could coordinate our
work is through meetings and most people
report that most of their meetings are
not very useful or productive
you and i spent some time a while ago
discussing how we can improve meetings
do you want to share some of those
thoughts that we discuss
oh well there's there's lots of
different
thoughts one is the first thing i look
for in addition to the usual sort of
size of meetings and uh and so on is uh
is that when you are a leader and you're
in a meeting there's three measures that
we use and in fact
we we use this in our classes even we
did a class with startup ceos and we had
our students analyze their worst
meetings and help them improve them and
the three metrics that uh that that we
tend to look for this is huggierow and
me
is just pure talking time so if we go to
a ceo and he or she talks the whole time
that's a bad sign the second thing is we
look at the proportion of statements
they make versus the number of questions
they ask and if i was going to pick a
model ceo you know back in the 90s
i used to go to a a monday morning
meeting at ideo a famous innovation uh
firm that was
led by david kelly who founded ido
founded the stanford d-school astounding
person he's won every award there is
just about as an ethnographer i'd go
there it'd be a one-hour meeting david
would talk six or seven minutes of that
whole hour and he he started out with a
self-deprecating joke maybe tell his
story 60 people in the room he would go
around he'd ask 25 or 30 of them um
questions and so if you look at that
criteria it was he probably talked 12
minutes out of 60 and he probably would
ask 30 questions and make 10 statements
and then probably tell 15 jokes in
response to uh would people describe
what they did over the weekend so if
you're a boss shut up and ask more
questions
i actually recommend that people on
their agendas or their meeting
invitations they actually send out
questions to to get it even started
before you meet so people come in ready
to engage and answer those questions
i love that and one of the other things
you and i talked about was this notion
of psychological safety i'm wondering if
you can comment on that so if people
feel safe they tend to feel better about
contributing in meetings isn't that
right
yes so so this comes from research uh
harvard business school researcher named
amy edmondson she's been saying this for
30 years she's got a new book the
fearless organization and and
essentially what amy and now
there was large scale surveys at uh
google too that they found this was the
hallmark of great teams was
psychological safety so if you have a
situation where people are afraid to
speak out afraid to argue
um then you end up having uh well fewer
voices involved and you had having more
mistakes made and you also end up um
people get alienated they try less hard
and there's there's
evidence even that when people don't
speak up you end up with terrible
fiascos like the space shuttles explodes
exploding
more surgical errors more drug treatment
errors so
so as a leader your job is to make it
safe and and one and what one thing that
i always kind of like to say to bosses
is kind of like who annoys you the most
on your team okay
and and those people the typical
solution
response is to kind of like not listen
to them to shut them down well if if the
most annoying people might person might
be the most useful person too so that's
one way to to uh sort of ask them about
is
how you handle your most annoying
co-worker might be a sign of how much
psychological safety there is and and so
what i'm really hearing you say bob is
that as somebody who runs meetings you
really need to spend time not just
focusing on the content and the specific
agenda but also how people feel and show
up
and that and a lot of people don't
they're just so focused on the task and
not on the actual socio-emotional
well-being of the people involved yet
that really matters yeah and and one
thing i would say to add to that is is
you know one of my many mantras is
silence is not golden people who are
silent um one of the advantage and
there's all these disadvantages this
online stuff but in the zoom stuff when
when you have that uh layout where you
can see everybody's faces you actually
see who is not talking and and one thing
that i started doing with my classes and
it sounds like you have too i just did
it yesterday there was three people who
didn't say anything out of my 12
students and so i took an extra five
minutes and i called on each one of them
i said you haven't spoken and each one
of them
really appreciated being called on and
they said something really smart and
probably smarter than the rest of us
because they've actually been listening
and and so so so this notion of i think
what good leaders do is that they they
make it safe and encourage uh people who
talk less to sort of add something to i
love that and i do spend a lot of time
calling on people who are silent and
you're right in the virtual world you
can see that more readily than than when
we're in person
speaking of this transition to remote
work and remote communication what best
practices can you provide beyond the
calling on the silent people that help
us not just survive but thrive in our
zoom skype teams hangouts webex
menagerie
well i think we're all struggling in
this uh journey together uh the first
thing that that i would start out with
and this is for those of us who are
teachers who are executives and also
just having control over our calendar
is that uh is that
for emotional and cognitive reasons
we've got to
pace ourselves and encourage people to
pace one another so this means the
meetings have to be shorter this means
there has to be breaks um this means um
and some of the folks of the design
school are really cool about this
consider doing 35 of your meetings audio
only
because you get emotionally exhausted by
seeing people's face in front of you
and there's a bunch of evidence because
what happens is you're both um more
emotionally aware
and you have thinner cues at the same
time so to me there's a thing about the
pacing oh and the other thing i'm
learning this in my classes and maybe i
should learn this before that um anytime
anybody talks more than six minutes it's
too long or seven minutes right maybe
i'm committing that sin right now
too much but it is interesting because
after just it's i think because we have
more incomplete cues that it starts
sounding like warm warm water
a few minutes earlier than in in live
meetings yes
those are some of the things that that
come to mind but a lot of it is just
tending to the emotions and dealing with
the fact that it's just more cognitively
and emotionally exhausting yes and and
just to echo a few things that you said
there's research that i'm aware of that
says that after eight to ten minutes you
really need to change something up just
so people are reinvigorated so it could
be change a speaker ask a question show
a video just something to re-stimulate
people and with regard to looking at all
the faces on the screen not only is it
demanding to look at everybody else's
faces but we also see ourselves more
frequently and that self-awareness is
draining too and so one of the things
that some of the research i'm aware of
has suggested is at the beginning of
meetings show your image make sure
people are connected face to face and
then if you have slide wear or demos go
to that remove the faces and then come
back to faces when you're actually doing
interactions so you give yourself a
break within the actual meeting and that
that i think could be helpful too but
that the psychological drain of just
having to be on with less cues fewer
cues is absolutely a true
challenge for people
now bob you've written many books and
they are all incredibly insightful and
helpful let's imagine you've been
contracted to write the definitive
rulebook for effective teaming and work
what would rule number one be in your
new book
well i'll steal
rule number one from my worst selling
book weird ideas that work
weird ideas that work is about how to uh
create creative uh teams and
organizations and the rule is find some
happy people and get them to fight what
so first of all
when you bring a team together i'm not
sure happiness is the right word but you
want trust you want psychological safety
but there's all sorts of evidence that
when people argue in an atmosphere of
mutual trust that they're more likely to
bring different perspectives they're
more likely to develop the best ideas
and the person i think of here as sort
of the hallmark or the star of this is
brad bird the academy award-winning
director from um
from pixar the incredibles movies for
example the way that brad describes it
and we've seen him we've got video of
him when you're on a team with brad bird
essentially you're involved in if you
will loving conflict as one member of
his team put it every day
and that's what you do you you do that
because that's how you come up with the
best solutions and brad will make a
decision because he's got to make a
movie but you've got to have
constructive conflict and and so that i
guess that's sort of what i would say
find some happy people and get them to
fight and also related to that the best
teams know when to fight how to fight
and when it's time to stop fighting and
implement the decision even if you
disagree with it i love that your first
rule is counter-intuitive you know most
of us just want happy people so we don't
have conflict but if people feel safe if
they feel supported in sharing their
different viewpoints i can totally see
how you can get more creative more
diverse ideas and and actions coming out
of that thank you
so bob before we end i like to ask all
guests the same three questions so i'm
hoping you're willing to answer my three
questions if you were to capture the
best communication advice you have ever
received as a five to seven word
presentation slide title what would it
be
how about
uh be confident but not really sure
and the the reason i say that
and this is other related sayings this
is from research on wisdom uh is have
strong opinions weekly held so i i like
people when they communicate when and
when they're leaders um and we're
certainly seeing this in covid to
express confidence about what they
believe to be true right now and it and
to
sort of inspire us all to action while
at the same time to acknowledge to
themselves and others that we don't know
everything and they're always open to
new input
so so to me i i don't i don't want a
leader who's insecure about everything
and i don't want a leader who if he will
have strong opinions uh strongly held
who won't update no matter what so
either strong opinions weakly held or to
be confident but not really sure that's
that i that's sort of what i would start
with
confidence with humility and being open
very cool so you've mentioned a lot of
leaders that you've worked with i'm
wondering is there one particular
communicator that's really impressed you
and and you admire and why is that
right so you asked me this question a
little bit before and i've been
friending over it the first person who
came to mind was uh president obama the
second uh was uh kara swisher the new
york times columnist who was really
entertaining but the person i settled on
actually is one of my own bosses which
is sort of amazing since if you ask me
some of my bosses at stanford they'll
tell you i don't admire them but but but
in going through the covid uh crisis
with my dean in the school of
engineering jennifer whittam
she has been
so down-to-earth so human and and back
to this confident but not really sure
stuff
she's confident she's empathetic but at
the same time she will say to us is
we're in a changing situation we don't
know what's going to happen in the world
we we don't know what's going to happen
in the university so let's do the best
we can and move forward so so
this is somebody you know i've had some
kind of communications with every two
weeks or so so so i actually am
shockingly picking my own boss i am
shocked i know jennifer and she's
wonderful i'm just shocked that you
picked your boss uh that that's awesome
and jennifer is great and and i've had
an opportunity to see her work and she
is very empathetic and down to earth for
sure yeah so our last of the three
questions is what are the first three
ingredients in your mind that go into a
successful communication recipe
well i'll pick a kind of a covid one
which is which is that
especially we're at a time when um a lot
of difficult decisions are being made
and being implemented not just layoffs
as many people are doing but uh but
but doing things like uh shutting down
buildings uh opening and closing and
stuff and and
one of the things that there's a bunch
of research to support this is is that
when you're leading people during
difficult times a lot of what your job
is
is uh is to give them as much
predictability as you can give them as
much understanding and as much control
and
and sort of the headline of that would
be something like there's a difference
between what you do and how you do it so
let's just say that you may have to lay
off people or do pay cuts because of how
difficult it is but
having them understand when it's going
to be happening i'm having having to
understand why it's occurring and to
understand what elements of control they
have over the way the decision is
implemented to me that's a hallmark of a
good leader so prediction understanding
in control wow
very helpful and i can imagine that
would lead to much more success even if
the messages and communications are
challenging yep well thank you bob you
certainly didn't disappoint uh your
ideas for helping us work better meet
more effectively and taking care of
ourselves and others have been really
insightful useful and quite frankly a
lot of fun so thank you for your time
and i wish you well
thanks matt
thanks for joining us for another
episode of think fast talk smart the
podcast
produced by stanford university's
graduate school of business for more
information and episodes visit
gsb.stanford.edu
or subscribe to our show wherever you
get your podcasts